freunde herzlich willkommen in der
teilweise sehr sehr schönen stadt
frankfurt wir sind heute hier um
verschiedene fußballs zu testen wir
haben die gesamte bandbreite am start
wir haben fried chicken und pizza wir
haben currywurst wir haben frühstück und
noch viel mehr gehen wir erstmal zum
frühstück ab china ski-idol
schon mal vorkommen danach ja
so wir sind vor unserem ersten platz wir
sehen schon die wunderbare
blumendekoration draußen eric schwärmten
hier schon seit wochen und monaten vor
deshalb habe ich ganz vor erwartung
schauen wir mal rein
[Musik]
auch hiervon hat mit eric vorgeschwärmt
es gibt einfach eine richtig stabil
aufbereitete online pate und die sachen
die sich hier so zeigen sind auf jeden
fall auch stabil was ist deine
empfehlung was hast du hier gegessen was
ich komm du für macy's
sandwiches heim bacon und schießen das
ist das kult iv oder dem gedämpften bau
band was mich auch anlass ist auf jeden
fall das passiert dann ist der match
aber das ist für mich nicht so ne 10 ich
sage ehrlich die experten bestelle ich
nie weil das hängt mir so zur nase raus
aber hier sehen wie grass habe mich
nicht so gut entscheider das ja schon
einen trieb das zeichen bei einem
frühstück werden aber auch kein vorteil
selber ins kiesbett und ihr seht aber es
gibt noch ein anderes
um 6 uhr ist er käme das erbeutete
andere mal zu schreiben ich finde das
aber so schon so viele sind einfach
nicht konzentrieren kann und so ich kann
ganz schön rum reden ich muss mir direkt
ja sollen sandwich packen man merkt
wirklich schon am 8 es ist quatsch wir
gehen direkt in den abo kabel befreien
ich guckte er
oder das ist einfach der big mac unter
den frühstückstisch würdest du hast zwei
lagen brot zwischendrin hast du was aber
es hat mich zu diesem burger geschmack
sondern es hat uns immer so dass ein
plastischer so mit dem brot schmeckt das
einfach literweise fed also auch mit den
kommentaren
sehr sehr lecker auch sehr wichtig nicht
tot gedacht so da ist nicht irgendwie
noch so ein cookie dough dabei oder so
sondern das ist einfach so normale
zutaten sehr opulent angerichtet rainer
kranz das also ein frühstück nachdem die
schlafen legte ich probiere schnell für
euch corona park anscheinend einen haus
spezialität - ecke aber mit kokosnuss
probieren
war das ist unnormal endlich zwei
verbüßte was windows recke erwartet wo
man sieht hier der cream cheese oben
braucht ganze auch sehr lieb war
angerichtet hier könnt ihr euch diesen
gewissen frühstücken schicken soll was
für die story dabei der nächste spot das
ist auf jeden fall nicht richtig stabile
currywurst essen und das bei best for
stimmt auch
[Musik]
ich merke schon dass ein besonderer ort
hier sind bei der ersten filialen von
best worscht es gibt es mittlerweile
ganz oft in frankfurt haben kumpel
gefragt wer hier wohnt und er meinte
hier musste vorbei kommt es geht harry
wurst in allen möglichen aufträgen es
gibt aber eine monats bewusst mit ananas
gerade ich habe gedacht ich teste für
euch und zu bewerten meint den klassiker
also einfach ein normaler currywurst
special hier mit röstzwiebeln eine sind
currywurst und klassisch frühen
morgenstunden mit 55.000 zwar will also
schon ein bisschen schon sehr gespannt
eric hat mir auch davon vorgeschwärmt
nicht unangenehm ich bin erleichtert
aber richtig danke auf die super crunchy
beim reinbeißen man hat trotzdem sondern
leiste geschmacks schärfe also man
schmeckt trotzdem was super cars ist man
kann nicht halt ganz viele verschiedenen
soßen geschmäcker zusammen konfigurieren
es gibt sie auch schärfegrade
facebook.com der rocker soll das ist so
6 millionen scoville oder so wäre dann
spaß soll es machen aber so ist auf
jeden fall richtig ist aber auch dass
genommen bald in frankfurt der standard
ist das hier ist jetzt die lemon
variante mit schweine- und was
interessant ist alles hat so diese basic
grundlage und dann kommt so ein pulver
drauf und das thematisieren man weiß
dass man im herzen europas mitten in
deutschland ist es gibt ein schönes
großen rot das war wirklich jeder sein
also hab ich damit sagen wir gehen zum
nächsten
[Musik]
wow das sieht sehr gut aus hallo freunde
ich melde mich aus der zukunft aus dem
urlaub einmal bewusst geworden ist wie
wichtig es ist nicht einfach den ganzen
tag nur frankfurt auseinander nimmt
sondern dass man es ja mal was gesundes
zuführt wer käme der beste in frage als
meinen partner co
falls ihr es auch einmal so einen
wunderbaren margarine was shot können
wollten jacob oder auch wenn ihr so ein
herrliches protein porridge dem
frühstück sein könnten die beiden sachen
und viele an und klickt ihr auf jeden
fall auch korrupt und dem q5 max 55
unterstützt mich unterstützt mein
partner das war schon von mir ist nichts
weiter meinen urlaub noch viel spaß mit
dem video wo ich finde es riecht ernst
so anders verstehen kommt also es riecht
so richter anders als man es kennt und
von der präsentation her auf so einem
geilen aluminium trailer noch so dieses
papier so das ist so ein bisschen
american aber man sieht trotzdem so
zusammen und so weiter vor dass hier
wieder die farbe an und wirklich dass
viktor ein halbes kilo ich glaube es
gibt dazu gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel
zu sagen man muss den geschmack sprechen
müssen die kleine frühlings team in
nordhessen
so der saft steht wenn man daran weil
der kran ist komplett krank ich dachte
schon fast weil das so helles gold ist
dachte ich das vielleicht nicht so krank
aber verrückt rand das ist nicht eine
parade das ist so eine höhe ja sagen zum
glück ist die panade ob man sieht dass
hier überhaupt nicht so dick ich hatte
nämlich wirklich sorge dass in so einem
teigmantel ist der 1er schlägt ich
glaube es dabei ist trotzdem so ein
bisschen teig irgendwo wo es ist wie so
eine schutzschicht die näher darüber
gemacht haben und
wir haben auf empfehlung von einem
zuschauer der hier arbeitet die sohle
mayonnaise genommen mit mario ingwer
sesamöl chili und ich sage euch ehrlich
diesen zehn also
mayuka der mann hat geschmack auf jeden
fall ich dachte so was willst du fried
chicken sagen wir haben in köln hängt
den verrückten curri fried chicken sport
aber das ist etwas ganz anderes
das ist richtig richtig gut nicht zu
unrecht haben wir den ganz ganz viele
empfohlen den spot probierten wir mal
eine von diesem gitter kartoffeln auch
mit einer speziellen
ich probiere jetzt auch einmal vertraut
oder
das geräusch wenn schon dieser welt
diese panade daran dass qualität und
auch so anders geige wird das ist nicht
nur also salz und pfeffer also besser
hätte ich nicht sagen können bands
schicken sein soll
er will jetzt erstmal kleinen
verdauungsspaziergang bevor es zum
nächsten spot geht jetzt schon ein
kleiner hund wir gehen zur oma wurde mir
auch ganz ganz oft vorgeschlagen falafel
die genres geschafft wahrscheinlich der
beste verlassen in der stadt das
überprüfen wir mal besser
wir wollen dir was ist euer bestes
heller verlassen muss er in der peter
aber okay hier super dann nehme ich das
einmal mehr das gute stück also ich muss
erstmal sagen die falafel sehen unnormal
crispy aus ein bisschen homos an der
seite aber was interessant ist dieses
peter groth sehr sehr weich ich kenne
das vor allem so von gyros pita oder so
also von einem griechischen restaurant
ansonsten ist das aber sehr traditionell
sind diese arabische eingelegt ist für
mich so der klassische schavan falafel
begleiter ich habe so ein fast vergessen
lassen wir so folgt
dann schmeckt direkt als das schöne
frische minze drauf der kühle joghurt
dann hat man so die wirklich sehr sehr
knusprig verlag wird mieter brot auch
superschön war ich verstehe auf jeden
fall warum denn so auf den fohlen wurde
das siehst du und anders als bei so
einem döner bis zu 17 toten und das
schmeckt einfach mitspielen
[Musik]
willst du die frische minze was sagst du
es willst schön frisch und natürlich
schon ein ding das ist mir jetzt gut
glaube ich noch nie so krasse falafel
geist ja und haben richtig viel zwiebel
anteil auch sind so sachen kennt ihr das
manchmal wenn so verlassen so mehlich
sind ziemlich die durch diesen hohen
zwiebel anteil sind die so übel saftig
wir können uns das ding erst mal ein
paar abschließende worte und und dann
geht es auch schon weiter ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass so krass ist ich fand
es so die schärfe die frische wie wenig
schwer es war und so das war eine ernste
10 das war richtig richtig gut so man
hat das gefühl man macht und man ist
auch bei seinem authentischen laden bei
so einem insider
zu recht haben das wirklich so viele
beschweren das ist so wenn nach köln
kommt sagen die die leute kebab land
wenn in frankfurt ist eigentlich ein
letztes wort haben in petto wir sehen
uns jetzt gleich bei super brot klingt
vielleicht bisschen komisch aber das war
eine der besten pizza leben
[Musik]
ja
das sieht auf jeden fall schon mal nicht
schlecht aus und wir gucken uns noch mal
ran diese kleinen bläschen wunderbar
unterboden sehr schön getigert ich habe
ja auch das eine oder andere mal schon
pizza gemacht wie sieht sehr sehr gut
das ding ist das ist jetzt genau das was
ich brauche das letzte was ich brauche
nach schmuck münzen tag essen wir können
uns mal ein stück zum lesen ein kleines
fenster test wird sich boden verneigen
der wohnung zu respekt
rote zwiebeln setzen könnte mozzarella
bisschen parmesan
statement
ich habe so viel gutes essen heute
gegessen weiß ich gar nicht mehr so
richtig somit ausdrücken kann weil ich
habe das gefühl ich sage das gleiche da
ich nicht wirklich weiß ich noch dazu
sagen soll weil es ist wieder super
lecker ist ja bekannt hat so eine schöne
pencil note schmeckt zurück so
authentisch italienisch was übrigens
autos was der laden hier claim zu
heimatverbundenheit frankfurter drückst
gar nicht enttäuscht
frankfurt aufgab geliefert wir mussten
uns was wir haben jetzt schon viele
läden drin aber wir mussten zuvor
reduzieren werden noch zehn weitere also
frankfurt hat auf jeden fall nicht nur
essens mäßig heute auf ganzer linie
überzeugt werden ein richtig schönen tag
noch ein stück von unseren teller
blitzer auch unter den nutella pizza ist
das eine der besseren licht weil ich mag
richtig gerne so dieses haselnuss
krokant umbau krank macht weiter so
danke fürs zuschauen leute wir sind vom
nächsten video wieder wie gesagt wir
wollen jetzt drücken
so haben wir das letzte wort
[Musik]